what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have some fantastic four news
today a little bit different than what
we've heard a couple of days ago we have
actually heard about some drama
happening over at Marvel Studios in
regards to the casting of the Fantastic
Four members the final casting of who's
going to be playing the official members
of the Fantastic Four Reed Richards Sue
storm Johnny Storm and Ben Grimm we
thought that it was already pretty
locked down in that the official cast
for The Fantastic Four had pretty much
been chosen however it turns out that
doesn't seem like the case however it
does seem like one particular member or
possibly two have been chosen for the
Fantastic Four team and like we
mentioned a couple of videos ago Marvel
Studios is trying to get this lockdown
as soon as possible so they can make an
official announcement at San Diego
Comic-Con Marvel's Hall h panel which is
a little bit over a month away right now
we also have some news about Tom Holland
as Spider-Man he has recently made some
comments about playing Spider-Man or I
should say about being done playing
Spider-Man that a lot of fans are asking
questions about no this does not mean he
has done a Spider-Man yes he did say he
would be happy to move on but we're
gonna break down exactly what this means
in this video so you don't have to worry
about a thing and if you love Marvel and
want to stay up to date with all the
recent news be sure to subscribe to the
channel we're also doing a giveaway
we'll talk more about that at the end so
just to very quickly go over what Tom
Holland said in a recent interview with
The Hollywood Reporter he did say he was
excited to come back for the fourth one
we're going to talk about that in a
separate video but then he said I'm a
little apprehensive about it there's a
bit of a stigma about the fourth one in
all franchises I feel like we hit a home
run with our first franchise and there's
a part of me that wants to walk away
with my head held high and pass the
Baton to the next lucky kid that gets to
bring this character to life there's a
lot more really great Spider-Man stuff
in this article that will break down in
another video but basically Tom Holland
did not say that he is done with
Spider-Man he's moving on he is stating
that Spider-Man no way home was
basically a home run it was a great end
to a Trilogy and he would love to walk
away with his head held high going yeah
that's how I ended my Spider-Man career
with the best Spider-Man movie there is
that he might want to do that rather
than make a fourth film than a fifth and
a sixth and them not be as good and then
end his career that way however he still
is going to continue to make these
Spider-Man films he did confirm that in
this article stating that he's already
met with Amy Pascal executive producer
over at Sony and Kevin feige again we'll
talk about that in another video but
just wanted to update everybody Tom
Holland has not done as Spider-Man he is
still very much Spider-Man however we
can't really say the same for the
Fantastic forecast that we knew or I
should say we thought we knew we have
some news from a couple of insiders that
is kind of concerning at this point in
time because it really doesn't sound
like anything is finalized with the
Fantastic Four with the exception of one
or maybe two actors in which that isn't
even finalized yet but it looks like
Margot Robbie might not be playing soon
storm in fact it does look like Sue
storm might be the only character that
has been officially cast at this point
in time and it's looking like it might
not be Margot Robbie but Vanessa Kirby
now we've talked about Vanessa Kirby in
the past her name has always been in the
mix of who Marvel Studios has been
looking at to play Sue storm The
Invisible Woman in the MCU I think she
is personally a great pick I really like
Vanessa Kirby as an actress she's got
great acting skills and I think she has
a really great look and at the same time
this is kind of in line with what Marvel
Studios has done before they take actors
and actresses who aren't exactly the
biggest ones yet or super well known but
then they become that way because of
their MCU roles I have nothing against
Margot Robbie at all I actually really
like Margot Robbie and I think she is
Iconic as Harley Quinn but she is
already super super famous and Marvel
Studios has had a history of not really
casting super famous actors of course
there are always exceptions like Sam
Jackson but of course it's always really
cool to see actors careers just explode
because of their Marvel characters like
Chris Hemsworth and Tom Holland it's
just fantastic to see now here's what
Grace Randolph recently said in a tweet
she said it's looking really in all caps
good I hear it might have happened I
also hear she was the director's First
Choice all along and she posted a
picture down below of the Tweet of
Vanessa Kirby now like I mentioned yes
we have heard her name out there for a
long time of a possible candidate for
Sue storm it does look like Marvel
Studios wanted her and the director Matt
shackman wanted her as well and we
talked about this last time but if you
get huge actresses like Margot Robbie
they do want more money and Vanessa
Kirby is amazing she has done some
amazing projects I love her but Margot
Robbie is more famous she has done many
iconic movies played many iconic roles
with many iconic actors around her I
mean she's about to be Barbie she is
Barbie and based off of what we've heard
before Marvel Studios wanted Emma Stone
to play Sue storm but she she wanted
more money than they really wanted to
give her so Vanessa Kirby probably
wouldn't want to get paid as much as
Margot Robbie or Emma Stone so that
would work out for Marvel plus if Matt
shackman wanted her the entire time that
probably means she tested extremely well
so I'm all for this and I hope it
happens and this could kind of be the
drama that people are talking about
right now Insider Daniel rpk recently
responded to a tweet that stated
Fantastic Four cast still not locked
question mark in which he responded
correct not locked at all a lot of drama
there now there's a lot of things that
this so-called drama could be about
We're Not Gonna speculate too much but
there are two things that could possibly
be getting in the way of finalizing the
Fantastic forecast in which again Marvel
Studios really wants to do very soon so
they can announce the official cast at
San Diego Comic-Con during their Hall
age panel so it's extremely important to
them to lock down this cast soon one of
the reasons they haven't yet could be
like we just talked about money if you
have big names like like Adam Driver and
Margot Robbie wanting 20 to 30 million
dollars to play this role then you have
actors like Paul mascal who could be
playing Johnny Storm wanting 15 to 20
million as well and then David Diggs who
could possibly be playing the thing
wanting 15 to 20 as well that's a pricey
movie that's a hundred thousand dollars
possibly for the cast and that's really
not even the cast we talked about this
before but Antonio Banderas could be
playing the villain Galactus that's
definitely another 30 million he's a
huge name so the drama could be the
actors want to play the role Marvel
Studios want the actors to play the role
but the actors want to get paid what
they think they are worth which I
totally understand but another thing
could go back to Grace Randolph's
comment that Mack shackman the director
wanted Vanessa Kirby all along Margot
Robbie could have been there and Kevin
feige could have wanted Margot Robbie
but the director Matt shackman could
have wanted Vanessa Kirby that's where
some drama could have been as well that
does happen and it's not always that big
of a deal but of course it can delay the
casting process now it might have worked
out in a way that Margot Robbie decided
to pass on it or Marvel Studios decided
to pass because Margo might have wanted
a little bit more money than they could
give in which case it fell down to the
second choice which could have been
Vanessa Kirby in which Mack Chapman
could have been extremely happy about
there's definitely a lot more that could
be happening behind the scenes but like
I said since we don't really know we
won't speculate too much I will say
though that Adam Driver playing Mr
Fantastic is still probably set he has
worked with Disney for a long time in
the Star Wars franchise he knows a lot
of people there he's close with a lot of
people there and I really don't think
Marvel and Disney have a problem paying
him what he believes he is deserved to
be paid so I think right now our Mr
Fantastic and our invisible woman could
be Vanessa Kirby and Adam Driver and if
that is so tell me what you think about
this would you be okay with that do you
see them as our Fantastic Four members
let us know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and if you subscribe and leave
a comment you're entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items as well we pick one winner at the
end of each month and the winner gets to
pick one item also we have a patreon
account now posting exclusive content we
have a Discord server and a website be
sure to check those out we'll link them
down below you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf
foreign